this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device called
the pod pro
cover by eight sleep it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature
it pairs dynamic cooling and heating
with biometric tracking to offer the
most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this so
i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys
you can get two hundred and fifty
dollars off of the pod pro cover that's
a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim or use code
tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-m-eight sleep dot
com
slash tim for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by four
sigmatic which
is part of my morning routine also part
of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings
i regularly start with their mushroom
coffee instead of regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee it's
easy on my stomach tastes amazing and
all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list
that's number one i travel with it i
recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the 60 percent of americans or
more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side
energizing side the next is
actually their chaga tea which tastes
delicious
it is decaf completely decaf
and some may recognize chaga it is
nicknamed the king of the mushrooms
it is excellent for immune system
support
so needless to say i am focused on that
right now
myself and so i will often have that in
the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out
every single batch is third party lab
tested for heavy metals allergens all
the bad stuff
to make sure that what gets into your
hands is what you want to put in your
mouth and they always offer a 100
percent money back guarantee
so you can try risk-free why not i've
worked out an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling lions
main coffee i literally have a mug full
of it in front of me right now
and this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39 percent off i
don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39 off it's a lot they're best
selling lions main coffee bundles to
claim this deal you must go to
4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on their regular website
go to four sigmatic that's
f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com tim to get yourself some awesome
and delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
checkout
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i'm going to skip my usual preamble
you guys have heard it before and i'm
going to get straight to this guest
because we are going to run
out of time before we run out of
material my guest today
is catherine that's with an ryn commonly
known as
katie han h-a-u-n on twitter at
katie k-e-t-i-e underscore han h-a-u-n
she is a general partner at andreessen
horowitz
previously she spent a decade as a
federal prosecutor focusing on fraud
cyber and corporate crime alongside
agencies including the sec
fbi and treasury she created the
government's first cryptocurrency task
force
and led investigations into the amount
gox hack
we might talk about what that is and the
corrupt agents on the silk road task
force i have quite a few questions about
that
while with the us department of justice
katie prosecuted rico murders
we'll define that organized crime public
corruption gangs and money laundering
so lots of good guys in other words she
also held senior policy positions at
justice department headquarters in both
the national security division and
attorney general's office
where her portfolio included antitrust
tax and national security
while in the private sector katie is
testified before both the house and
senate on the intersection of technology
and regulation
kd serves on the boards of coinbase and
hacker one and has invested in an
advised tech companies from
seed to series e stage she teaches a
management course at stanford business
school and previously taught cyber crime
at stanford law school katie clerked for
u.s supreme court justice anthony
kennedy
and is an honors graduate of stanford
law school she is a lifetime member
of the council on foreign relations
katie welcome to the show
tim thanks for having me great to be
here i am so excited
to chat for so many reasons and i
thought i would just set the tone
for people listening with
a few lines from our mutual friend naval
ravicon who is a
certainly a a crowd and listener
favorite
here on the podcast i
emailed naval to ask if there might be
any
questions or subjects so it would be
interesting to explore
with katie and of course
indicating that i would do my own
homework and he replied with the
following i asked him if i could give
attribution
and he said yes you can cite me so
here's what he said
this was his his very concise response
quote she has a concealed carry grew up
in cairo can't set foot in russia
dealt with a lot of violent criminals
etc but she's also a suburban mom with
kids and runs the number one
hard-charging vc fund in crypto
she's quite the character if i'm down to
one phone call instead of calling my
lawyer i'm calling katie
so so on top of that you seem to be the
child whisperer
from another mutual friend suna and she
talked about how
incredible you are with children so we
are going to run out of material
i think very easily and i want to start
if it's okay with you with the silk road
so the silk road is of great interest to
me
for a lot of reasons and principle
among those is the fact that i used to
work
many days a week out of glen park
library
in san francisco and uh and
so for those who don't know the the
founder
of the silk road who used
the handle dread pirate roberts
of course an allusion to the character
from the princess bride
was apprehended in glenn park library on
a day i happened
just not to be there so the fact that i
thought not to be i was not there i was
not there but it makes me
assume that i must have been sitting
right next to this guy
many many many times so for those who
don't know
just as an introduction could you
explain what the silk road
was so if you weren't at glen park that
day tim that means you
missed the lover's coral that the fbi
staged
in order to nab dpr's computer i don't
know if you read that story yeah i did i
did
i did actually nick bilton who ended up
writing an entire book about this was
also
just a few blocks away lived in the
neighborhood
so let's move into this and you can also
explain the
well maybe the silk road and then the
lovers quarrel why that was
in in any way tactically important so
the silk road as many of your listeners
probably already know but for those who
don't
is a darknet site and it's a site um
that you can buy anything from fake
passports or that you could buy anything
from fake passports
to heroin to fentanyl to drugs and just
all kinds of contraband right i was
actually not involved in the
investigation
into ross albrecht and dpr a lot of
people think
oh you ran the silk road case i was
actually involved in
what i'll call the twist of the silk
road case i was involved
in some of the agents who were
investigating dpr
and russell brooked in the silk road i
ended up having to prosecute
them so let me back up before we get to
that
and that by the way that started with a
tip that someone in the government was
up to no good
and moving cryptocurrency but before i
get into that
that twist piece um just to answer your
earlier question about the silk road so
there was this
as you mentioned dpr and the government
the us government for years was trying
to find out
who is dpr where is he or she located
are they in the u.s are they elsewhere
and
how are they running the silk road and
so they spend a number of years trying
to find out
and one of the kind of secret weapons
that the us government had
was an undercover federal agent who i'll
call
knob and knob is one of the people i
ended up prosecuting
but this undercover federal agent
befriended
the mastermind of the silk road dpr i
pause for just one second
so usually if someone has a placeholder
pseudonym it's
like jane john doe where is
knob coming from and is that with an n
or a kn
it's nob but if you think knob is a kind
of crazy handle
the personas that knob invented to
actually then extort
the mastermind of the silk road were
french made
and death from above so we can get into
that in a moment so
knob is just the tip of the iceberg
all right sorry to interrupt please
continue yeah well where were we we're
so we were at the silk road the
government's trying to figure out who's
the mastermind
and it has a couple different task
forces on that job one as i mentioned is
outside of washington dc
that's where nob and others are
befriending dpr and getting little clues
into
you know who or where is this person how
do they do that they do that by
having nob who's an undercover federal
agent befriend
online dpr ross ulbricht and so for
about two years knob and dpr are
communicating
almost daily and they become actually
friends if you read the chats they're
messages on the silk road website
um which the government leader sees they
become kind of
you know they engage in friendly banter
back and forth what did you eat today
oh what are you doing are you working
out and the reason for that
tim is those kind of little clues inform
the government well where is this person
at like are they online during hours in
the middle of the day
what kind of workouts are they doing are
they hiking the hills
what are they eating are they eating
salmon you know where where is that
found
right where is so just little clues over
two years really can help a government
investigation so
knob was getting these clues by
befriending ross holbrook and nob's
cover story was that he was had
connections to the criminal
underworld in latin america because he
was a drug cartel leader
and his his in to ross ulbricht was i
hey i want to buy your business your
silk road i like this business so that's
how the two started communicating
and somewhere along the way knob went
bad
knob became a double agent playing both
sides and extorting ross ulbricht
for hundreds of thousands of dollars at
the time of bitcoin which
today would be hundreds of millions of
dollars of bitcoin
or of dollars in bitcoin um but also
selling
russell brook secrets into the
government's own investigation using
that death from above moniker
[Laughter]
that's just incredible my understanding
and please correct me from wrong that
one of the
key elements of this story in
apprehending dpr was also the fact
and i want you to fact check this
understanding that this
wasn't where you kind of entered the
scene but is that he used
he made a bit of a rookie mistake and he
used the same
handle i think of something like altoid
or something like that
in multiple locations with his email
address that ultimately
allowed agents and law enforcement to
triangulate
at least that seems to have been a piece
of the puzzle i i might be
misremembering that but when you became
involved
what were the key elements that allowed
you to
figure out what was going on and then
prosecute effectively
so again i didn't prosecute ross but i
remember that case well because as you
note
tim he was apprehended in san francisco
so i actually
remember when he came into the federal
building at the justice department that
day
and you are right that there were some
mistakes
he was pretty good at obfuscating but
there were some mistakes and i think
there's a new york times article on this
that
the irs agent on the case gary alford
was kind of
just on the open web found a reference
to his real name on google somehow
so i think your memory is correct but of
course like you say it's a bigger piece
of a puzzle i mean it was a multi-year
investigation
it involved search warrants from what i
understand all over the world and
a number of different pieces of the
puzzle but one piece indeed was what you
said which is
the kind of rookie mistake of leaving a
few digital breadcrumbs
in the form of his real name that
ultimately led to his apprehension
and i should have been more specific by
prosecution what i meant
was in reference to the two federal
agents oh yeah one of which being
knob so because in this twist
i mean par as i understand it part of
what makes this
pretty fascinating is that
the sort of the technology itself some
of the technology that play
made it possible or at least facilitated
the
tracking of these digital breadcrumbs
yeah could could you speak to that
so actually i'll go a step further and
i'll say in law we have this concept
called but four you know but for this
this wouldn't have happened and i can
tell you that but for the blockchain
we would not have caught by the way you
said knob there are actually two federal
agents we'll get into that in a second
because it turned out there was another
rogue federal agent doing all kinds of
other things
who was on that silk road task force and
but for
the blockchain we would not have caught
these two corrupt agents
and i say that if i sound like i say
that with certainty it's because i'm
certain of it
we would not have caught them otherwise
and in fact the only reason
that we were able to investigate and
follow the flow of funds
was because of the blockchain technology
and without it
we wouldn't have been able to bring
these two individuals to justice in fact
they'd
still be today federal agents i'm quite
sure of that and
moreover they'd probably uh have over a
billion dollars worth of
criminal proceeds in the form of bitcoin
given how the price has gone up
yeah they would have been highly
resource
rich and enabled uh
sort of uh questionable characters
uh that i mean wow what an alternative
universe that would have been
so in this case if we could pause for a
moment
you seem to have a superpower
of getting in front of an audience and
this is certainly shown up in
in previous profiles of you cnbc and
elsewhere
getting in front of an audience of
people who come from all walks of life
such as
the members of a jury and getting them
to understand a topic they might have
not heard of before or that might be
very complicated
possibly complicated could you explain
for people who
have heard the term blockchain but
really don't know what it refers to
what the blockchain is well there are
numerous blockchains but let's just use
the example of the bitcoin blockchain
and it's essentially tim what it is a
massive ledger that keeps track of kind
of who owns
what and instead of some central entity
keeping track
it's instead done by what are called
nodes all over the world and
these nodes in the case of the bitcoin
blockchain are
called miners and the best way to think
of them in my mind is
think of miners like the workers who are
performing computing work to secure this
system
that keeps track of this ownership so
it's kind of this decentralized
not centrally controlled big huge ledger
that keeps track of who owns what does
that
it does paint a picture for you and it's
also the key things about the blockchain
is it's immutable no one can change it
and that turned out to be really
important in the case we're talking
about
because these agents while i was
investigating them
were agents the whole time so they were
hot on my trail they could look and see
what i
was learning they could peak in our
investigation
in other words the government wasn't
able to terminate them just because we
thought there was some
nefarious conduct afoot and so the
blockchain was actually really necessary
because
in in several instances they were
actually able to get
banks and financial entities to destroy
records
to cover up evidence of their crime they
also forged subpoenas
and um forged court orders and the like
i think burn bags
and because of flashing the badge hey
this is an undercover operation
bank so and so delete those records and
not surprisingly the banks complied
here's a federal agent with a subpoena
saying delete these records it's a
sensitive undercover operation
so the blockchain was really critical
because it was decentralized and
immutable meaning it can't be changed
we were able to follow the trail and
that's why i say but for the blockchain
we wouldn't have been able to bring this
case or this indictment in fact
i i mentioned knob but i didn't mention
the other agent the crazy thing is they
weren't even working together but
another agent on that task force who is
a secret service agent
on detail to the nsa who was one of the
us government's
experts in encryption technology it
turns out
he had stolen him 25 000
bitcoin from ross albrecht in the silk
road which today
that would be worth just over a billion
dollars
and and and he had staged by the way he
had made it look
like the silk road ross solbrook's
right-hand man who was by the way a
grandfather in utah if you can believe
that the right hand of the silk road he
had staged the whole thing to make it
look like
that individual had stolen the 25 000
bitcoin
so ross olbruck says you know what is my
right hand man doing
stealing 25 000 bitcoin from my side i
know it's him
i've got to take care of this and who
does he turn to to do the taking care of
nob the other undercover federal agent
who he's befriended over two years
so the details are quite crazy but i
will tell you again that
without that blockchain technology we
wouldn't have been able to get the
records because in the case of the
secret service agent
one of the things he did was he
transferred those 25 000 bitcoins
to an exchange called mount gox which
was a japanese exchange that had gone
belly up
well we went over to get the mount cox
records and they didn't have any they
had been you know the exchange had kind
of gone under
and mark karpeles i remember meeting
with mark karpeles in japan and mark
carpellos said you know
those records we don't have and by the
way you guys did a seizure you guys
being the us government did a seizure
warrant
for mount gox not just not only where we
hacked the
the feds seized it well guess who was
the affiant on the seizure warrant
it was none other than our secret
service agent who had stolen the 25 000
bitcoin
i mean really it is just built for
screenplay this entire story
now it seems like if i'm getting my
facts straight that there is one other
but for
possibly and that is the tip could you
speak i don't know how much of this is
public record at this point but
who did it come from or what was the tip
how much did you have to go on
i'll tell you what is public record um
and you know if listeners want you can
go read there's a 97 i think or 90 page
criminal complaint that lays out all of
the facts of this story online you can
just go google it
silk road agents it's out of san
francisco
but what happened was i was sitting in
my office in san francisco on another
crypto investigation
and one of the lawyers who used to be an
investigative journalist
pulls me aside said can i talk to you
about something else and i said what
he said you know you've got i think
you've got a
a mole or someone up to no good you know
on your payroll
they're moving um cryptocurrency and i
thought oh here sounds like a real
conspiracy theory which of course i was
in san francisco i hear a lot of them
right about
how the government is bad and you know i
thought okay
this poor agent i've got to go clear
this person's name because here is this
you know lawyer
former journalist spreading rumors and i
thought probably
he's moving bitcoin it's probably you
know on
a poorly backstopped undercover
operation so
i actually that was the tip i got and i
actually
was really started to look into it more
to clear the name
and just you know then i thought oh that
his information was correct but i did
look into it like i said i got a couple
agents
and it's not a popular thing to go to
agents and say i want to investigate
some other agents right
bet not not a crowd pleaser no so i but
i got a couple agents who knew a thing
or two about the blockchain and we
hopped on wallet explorer and started
looking at some flow of funds and saw
wow this is a lot of
uh cryptocurrency moving around and then
what what flipped in my mind tim was the
moment where i saw
emails that this individual had sent to
crypto exchanges saying please
delete these records and i thought now
if this is undercover
and you're in the government you don't
want to delete evidence you want to
preserve evidence so that's how i knew
something was amiss
but we only got a tip about one agent
and of course that one agent once we
kind of solved who done it
and we knew he was extorting ross
olbrichton the silk road and we knew he
was
selling information in the government's
case we thought oh that's probably who
stole the 25
000 you know bitcoin as well um
so we were just thinking that's that's
who did it it wasn't the silk road
administrator
but in fact i remember on christmas eve
getting a call from one of those agents
and he said kati i don't think it's him
the patterns the movement of money
the kind of services that what they were
using to obfuscate
they're not the same person the mo is
different and we've got someone else
who stole that bitcoin and so then we
launched kind of a separate
investigation tim into
who stole a billion dollars worth of
bitcoin a billion now
yeah if i could pause for a definition
please
sure what exactly is a federal
prosecutor oh
a federal prosecutor is so a lot of
people have heard of district attorneys
or da's
right that is a local prosecutor
a federal prosecutor is another name for
it as assistant u.s
attorney and a federal prosecutor takes
those kind of crimes that cross
state lines or that are of a certain
kind of subject matter
that the federal government has deemed
are also federal crimes now a lot of
things
could be both you could have certain
crimes that could be prosecuted at the
state level
or they could be prosecuted at the
federal level and then you have other
crimes that could only be done by one or
the other
so my job as a federal prosecutor was to
kind of investigate
and bring to justice where crimes had
occurred now
another important part of the job of
being a prosecutor is knowing when not
to bring
a case where even though the facts
support a charge
because what i always say is the
government wasn't hurting for business
unfortunately there are a lot more
criminals than there are resources to
prosecute
and so one of the things as a prosecutor
that you really want to do
is look for what are the worst of the
worst where are you going to get the
most bang for the buck here
what is your theory of punishment is it
deterrence is it punishment like why are
we doing this
and so you really need to look for kind
of
the most important cases and by
important i don't mean high profile
i mean important for justice to be
served
i would imagine i mean this is me
knowing nothing about this but
also important possibly as a setting of
precedent
or otherwise acting as a domino that
knocks over or helps to
possibly knock over other dominoes i'm
looking at a letter
which is online at a16z that's the
andreessen horowitz
website a16z.com and this is the
hiring announcement by ben horowitz
certainly of the namesake jason horowitz
ben has been on the podcast as well
so is mark for that matter and i want to
read
just a portion of this letter there's a
lot to it including some nicki minaj
lyrics for people who want to see
the chun-li lyrics i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna read those
but here it is quote as i learned more
about her career i was even more
impressed she stood up to murderous
motorcycle gangs and cartels shut down
organized crime nailed rico murderers
again that acronym that i wanted to find
i've uncovered the largest money
laundering in cyber crime rings and
stopped white-collar crime and public
corruption through it all her
prosecutorial record not a word i read
every day
was whatever in zero she never lost a
case not once not
ever okay so bookmark rico we're going
to come back to it
but okay what and i'm going to pull a
couple of possible answers
to my forthcoming question off the table
so the working harder or preparing
harder i understand that you do both
meaning you work and focus very
intensely and you've had
a reputation for that for a long time
but what
do you think you have done differently
or how have you approached things
differently that has
helped you to have this record well
that's a great question
if it's easier to kind of swap places
how would your friends who really know
you and have seen you over the years how
would they explain it if that's easier
to answer
well let me take a stab at both and i
will put a pin in rico we'll come back
to that i mean one of the jobs i had as
a federal prosecutor is going to before
a grand jury
right that's a secret jury presenting
evidence and seeking an indictment
another kind of job of a prosecutor
is meeting with the witnesses in a case
and trying to maybe get them to flip
bringing you know evidence to bear
developing evidence it's also working
with agents and it's to get
agents motivated in some cases to go you
know
work nights and weekends to go chase the
lead for example
the other thing that you do as a
prosecutor is you go to court just like
you see on tv you know law order like
the prosecutor stands up and
you know it makes arguments to the judge
if it's a judicial argument or if it's a
trial makes an argument to the jury so
that's a little bit about the job of a
prosecutor i think one of the things
as i think about it that i did
differently was well first of all i just
had an
amazing mentor at the justice department
so put a pin in that and we'll come back
to him in a minute
but one of the things i did differently
is just i think it's
really important to obviously you want
to make sure that you're charging the
right case and you know you have all
your evidence because
even though 95 of federal cases
plead guilty um at least in those days
they did
some go to trial and tim you never know
which ones are going to go to trial
or which ones are going to plead guilty
the ones you think oh they'll take a
plea
they surprise you uh the ones you think
will go to trial surprise you and take
the first plea like you just never know
and so
one thing i always did is i thought to
myself i have to prepare this case
as if it's going to go to trial and i
have to convince a jury
and how am i going to convince that jury
that this is the right case to bring
that is righteous
and that the law was violated and that
what i'm asking for
is frankly a no-brainer one of the
things i did
was i developed something called well i
didn't develop
the concept of a reverse proffer but
i'll tell you about what i did
that is sometimes you just felt like
maybe
there's something lost in translation
like maybe this defendant doesn't
understand
the evidence i have against them who
knows like maybe their lawyers telling
them maybe they're not telling them
maybe they're telling them but the the
defendant doesn't really trust their
lawyer
and so i did something called a reverse
proper which is
i said with the you know permission of
defense counsel and defendant i said hey
would you let that defendant come into
my office marshalls
and if they did marshalls can you bring
the defendant to the office
if the defendant was in custody they'd
come you know shackled if they were out
of custody they'd just show up in a
you know street clothes with their
lawyer and i would sit him down
in the conference room at my office and
i would give them a little snapshot of
here is a kind of flavor or sampling of
the evidence i have against you
that a jury is going to hear and here's
how i'm going to present it
and i want you to be aware like with
this
evidence staring you down in the face do
you want to
go to trial or not and i think a lot of
times
seeing what would be presented and
seeing oh we do have they do have all of
these witnesses who will say x y and z
cause the defendants in some cases to
say no i want to change the
circumstances here
i want to like stop the bleeding so to
speak because obviously if you go to
trial
the sentences tend to be longer the
judge pronounces always the judge
pronounces the sentences but
when you're in a trial setting you often
get a lot longer than if you
take an earlier guilty plea so reverse
proffer was one thing
i think another thing that comes to mind
is just being able to develop a rapport
not just with the defendants or defense
counsel but with the witnesses
you know witnesses are some of the most
important evidence that you can have in
an investigation
and in a number of cases i was doing
particularly gang cases
why is some witness or some member of
the gang like why are they going to
trust you
a government prosecutor what can you do
to build that trust
and to really talk to them in a way that
is relatable and i think that was
something that i spent a lot of time
trying to develop is
putting myself as i can never put myself
in the shoes of some of the
folks that i encountered but trying as
best i could to think
what's motivating them what might they
be scared of
what's holding them back from wanting to
cooperate with us
and through doing some of those things i
think we were successful in being able
to flip some key witnesses
um so that could contribute to it but i
would be remiss if i didn't say that
i had just an amazing mentor he was
actually my boss
at the justice department and he was an
incredible
prosecutor and just watching him that
also
i think accounted for a lot of it so i
can't and also i had incredible case
agents
and fbi agents and everything so i can't
really take credit for all the
you know verdict records there's a lot
that goes into it
yeah i would imagine it's a team effort
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs the new year is here
and it marks a fresh start for your
small business whether you're shifting
business hours or hiring more remote
employees
one thing that remains unchanged is the
importance of having the right people on
your team
when your business is ready to make that
next hire linkedin jobs can help by
matching your role with qualified
candidates so you can find
the right person quickly and to lend a
helping hand
your first job post is free getting
started is easier than ever with new
features to help you find qualified
candidates quickly
from linkedin's active community of
professionals with more than
722 million members worldwide
post a job with targeted screening
questions to get your role in front of
more qualified candidates
you can manage job posts and contact
candidates on the familiar linkedin.com
website
where functions are streamlined into one
simple screen
and now you can do all this from your
mobile device no matter where the day
takes you
when your business is ready to make that
next hire find the right person with
linkedin jobs
and now you can post a job for free just
visit linkedin.com
tim again that's linkedin.com tim
to post a job for free terms and
conditions do
apply
if we take a closer look at this mentor
what were some of the things if
different from those you've just
mentioned
that stand out as making him an
excellent prosecutor
so or an unusually good oppressor yeah
well i think the key
thing is he did not care i mean i'm not
suggesting prosecutors
most career prosecutors are not thinking
of their next job so just to be clear on
that but
really with him and his his name is will
franson you know i've worked with a lot
of amazing mentors tim
and my career justice kennedy the
attorney general tech ceos
and folks in vc but this guy is not a
household name
his name is will frensen and i think one
of the things that comes to mind when i
think of will
is he just didn't care about
anything other than just in that moment
doing the right thing
and doing justice and he didn't care
about what his next job was going to be
he didn't care about the consequences
he didn't really even care i'm not
endorsing this necessarily but
he i remember some judges remembering
court once where a judge said you know
mr franson
why do you shake your head at me like
that like i'm stupid you know
no judge would ever usually say that to
a prosecutor but he had this
and and um will had this prosecutorial
swagger
that you know was unique to him he took
down emma's 13
i mean that's what i think there was a
newspaper article that described well's
prosecutorial swagger
but in my case one of the things he did
that made him an amazing leader was he
first of all threw me into the deep end
but he also had my back when i needed it
and he recognized when i was ready to
lead you know in fact i i did a biker
murder case
involving the mongols and the hells
angels and it went to trial
that was the one of the ones that i
thought for sure would plead guilty and
instead went to trial and it lasted
two plus months and you know will became
my second chair he became my deputy even
though he was my boss
and you know it was a high profile
murder case he sat second chair during
that case
but i think he also had my back and when
i tell you he doesn't really care about
his next job
can i share a story involving google
sure yeah
yeah well so there was a murder case we
were doing a different one than the one
i just mentioned
it was a gas station robbery to keep
track yeah
well this was it you have a lot of a lot
of murders
yeah it was a really sad circumstance um
of a guy who was shot over 250
while he was working a second job at
night and actually we had
some amazing evidence that we knew was
in the defendant's google
mailbox it was like google voice records
and stuff and so we
issued we got a search warrant which is
you know different than a subpoena we
had to go to the court we had to go to a
judge
prove probable cause and get a search
warrant and google just simply put it in
the line and basically told us to get in
line
and we'll get to it when we get to it
and we said you know this is a court
order
this is now unsealed so i can say this
publicly at the time it was it was
sealed
he said this is a court order it's the
murder case you know we need these
records and they basically told us what
we're google
we'll we'll get to it when we can get to
it and you know will said you know
that's just
bs i mean we go around expecting mom and
pop
stores all the time to comply with
search warrants or people
right ordinary citizens like why should
google get a pass and i said you're
right that's bs like let's
write a motion to the judge to have them
held in contempt we'll give them a fair
chance to comply first but if they don't
like let's go to the court
they should comply with the same rule
everyone else has to
and um we gave them several chances and
we said we're gonna go to court and they
basically ignored us and uh you know we
are google we will crush you
we went to court we got them held in
contempt of federal court if they didn't
produce these records
what ended up happening and this was all
under seal at the time
was i won't name names but someone at
google high up
called the political appointee who was
running our office at the time and
basically
suggested that we should get this undone
and you know we were in the jurisdiction
of google you know we're in the northern
district of california and will and i
were both like
no why should we do that like they
didn't this is a murder case
where the victim's family is relying on
us to you know bring the best case and
the best case involves those records
and we're not going to just stand back
because it's google you know calling up
and
suggesting we undo this motion so we we
stuck to it
and that was a case where will and
another boss might have said you know
let's kind of
figure out a way to broker a great
settlement here and make this go away
and he
said i don't care who they are you know
he really just didn't care so he was
fearless
and also he was egoless like i said he
let me often
kind of when he knew i was ready to lead
he would let me
first chair a case so that really stands
out to me
fearless and egoless is a
formidable combination right
very rare rare and i do not want to
fight that person on anything
that's going to be very difficult now
you mentioned fearless
and you also mentioned you know hells
angels mongols this might be a good
place to define
rico i don't know if that's related to
racketeering it is
see you got it right there racketeering
it's the racketeering and organized
corrupt
um i think institutions or racketeering
yeah and corrupt organizations and it's
basically a federal statute
where it just creates a class of crimes
that are more serious if you've done
certain predicate crimes
so for example it often involves cases
involving conspiracies and then you
allege several predicate acts so in
furtherance of the conspiracy maybe
there was some
you know gun trafficking maybe there was
money laundering maybe there was fraud
um and so i did a number of rico there's
also i'm not going to bore you with
acronyms but there's vicar
those are kind of this class of cases
again
where you're talking about a corrupt
organization that's the co
enrico our ico and what it means is
basically an
organized criminal enterprise and you
have to prove they were organized you
have to prove they were serving a
common goal you have to prove they did
certain things in furtherance of that
organization or conspiracy is basically
what rico is
does that also help you to prosecute
people who are in leadership positions
who don't necessarily for instance carry
out
a hit or murder themselves but they
issue the
order for that hit does rico
play a or the i suppose
not sure if laws is the right way to put
it but does that assist you in any way
in prosecuting thinking about these
larger groups hells angels mongols
you mentioned ms-13 for instance yeah
it's definitely a tool
in a prosecutor or an agent's toolkit to
kind of wrap up
an organization like you said if
otherwise the
individual might not have been on the
hook for actually like a murderer
maybe they just commissioned it for
example now there are other laws that
you can do tim you don't only need rico
there are conspiracy laws
but rico is just kind of another tool
that one might use and it also enables
you at trial
to get in what are known as like i just
mentioned predicate acts so
um you know at the hell's angels and the
mongols trial we included
predicate acts like there's i don't know
if you remember the laughlin river run
riot
and a series of other murders and
a whole host of other criminal conduct
that then the jury
heard and we think you know that not we
but the
congress who passed the law because of
course prosecutors don't make the law
they just enforce thaw
and so congress passed this law saying
that the jury would be able to hear
all of these different kind of predicate
acts
now standing up to google is
or a company like google right a tech
company with incredible power
wide reach shows a level of
fearlessness with respect to i suppose
many aspects of life including possible
maybe maybe not career advancement
career options later who knows like
politicking within the office etc
when you're dealing with say prison
gangs right like nuestra familia one of
the world's largest prison gangs
and other groups that are associated
with intense
violence how have you thought about
personal safety
and i'm struggling to ask a more pointed
question
but like what is the self-talk
been so that you can operate effectively
in a job that entails what i would
imagine to have some degree of personal
risk
and that's a that's a meandering
question but i'd love to at least open
the door to
just hearing your thoughts on that
because i don't know if i would have the
courage to do it quite frankly i think
you know you might if you see
some of the victims families and you
might if you kind of saw some of the
witnesses that were intimidated
or some of the consequences if you
didn't i mean i i
i completely hear what you're saying tim
and i i don't
you know dismiss it because it's
certainly something that i've thought
about
but i also knew that in those moments
there was something really wrong going
on and someone had to step in and do
something about it you know and it
wasn't just me
it was like i said a lot of really brave
men and women
law enforcement personnel and other
prosecutors and by the way judges and
even juries
you know jury there are plenty of
instances of jury intimidation but
you know it's critical for our system to
work
because obviously we can't just be
running amok with no laws and you know
violence i think in the case of noise or
familiar you mentioned a prison gang
this is an entire world people don't
realize i mean
and you think oh they're in prison so
therefore
then they're locked up but the truth of
the matter is and there's actually a
great 60 minutes episode on this it's
called operation black widow by the way
running criminal enterprises from prison
is
pretty common you know there's a whole
system that goes into taxing
criminal activity on the outside in
exchange for protection on the inside
and the people who are running these
gangs frankly a lot of them could be
running businesses i sometimes think if
circumstances were different they're
hustlers they're
dedicated you know they have a lot of
passion i'm not trying to
make it sound glamorous at all because
it is criminal i'm just
saying that they're very organized they
have a whole system for getting messages
outside i remember once a judge said to
me what do you mean that defendant is
you know under the influence of
whatever drug it was they're in prison
and i thought oh your honor like it's so
naive to think that
they're not able to get contraband in
prison they're running the prisons
sometimes um
and so this case you mentioned nuestra
familia was a was a really large gang it
was
you know they affiliate on the outside
with the nortenos
on the street and then like i said
there's a whole tax system
some of the street gangs will pay into
tax essentially
into inside the carnales inside so that
if they ever get
hooked up and put in prison then they're
protected
within prison but one thing i think that
um you might think oh these dangers when
you say
large just could you give us an idea of
what large means
well they're worldwide i mean you know
like in the case of ms-13 or nuestra
family i mean these
it's not just in the us but they're
certainly in every city i mean you're
talking about thousands and thousands
if not tens of thousands of individuals
affiliated with these
um but i prosecuted nuestra familia i
indicted that case
this was before that silk road case this
is in my violent crime days still
and um you you talk about being scared i
mean
the truth of the matter is a lot of the
defendants that
win and we extradited many from all over
the country and these were the kind of
carnales these were the
big chiefs these weren't like the street
level gangs these guys
so the carnalists are the leaders yes
within
and i think we indicted over a dozen
most ended up pleading guilty some did
go to trial but
you know you think oh well those are
going to be the scariest of the scary
but you know again like i told you
earlier it's really a human thing and
different people even if they're in a
really violent prison gang
react differently to things now a lot of
and i think a lot of the listeners
also myself i would include myself and
probably even this like we think oh it'd
be the worst thing in the world to go to
prison like we don't want to go to
prison
the interesting thing is a lot of the
people involved in these prison gangs
don't necessarily think that way tim
it's like it's not really a threat to
say i'm going to put you in prison
that's kind of like where they shine
sometimes
and so talk about trying to deter
criminal activity against that backdrop
but
i think because of that a lot of
those individuals sometimes think this
is the cost of doing business like
i'm gonna get you know hooked up part of
the game part of the game so it's not a
personal thing and the thing i try to
always
do is to just treat the defendants with
respect
treat all the subjects with respect and
not make it personal
and we ended up flipping a kind of key
witness in that case
a guy who is now in the witness
protection program so i won't say too
much about him
but he did end up testifying so i can i
can tell you that because it's all
public record
he was a newest family enforcer and he
was a hulking huge guy with tattoos who
came in and out of my office for weeks
and
as we tried to flip him and he
eventually came around to testify but
you know
most of them i mean it's kind of
violates i think
an oath to the gang that you would never
testify
um that is the worst thing you could do
in in the gang's eyes
i bet so so you mentioned earlier
that one might imagine that these cases
would be
the scariest is there a moment or a case
or an incident if you're willing to
share
where you were actually scared rightly
or wrongly
you know i i don't really want to get
into it because i i call it opsec tim
let's just say i've taken measures
and i won't really say much more than
that
you know you mentioned i have a ccw it's
not because i'm a gun nut or i'm
passionate about guns it's just because
you know you want to make sure you can
always protect yourself and i've taken
other measures as well
and i obviously i'm not going to get
until i'm here but i think like i said
it's really just in the moment of that
case
you just feel like your job and i felt
like my job
was to actually as cheesy or cliche as
it sounds pursue justice
and what kind of message would that send
if i just like
walked off the case or walked away and
certainly
a lot of people i worked with felt that
way too it wasn't just me bringing these
cases
there are a whole lot of other people
that in in some way reflects
well it certainly reflects i think deep
aspects of your personality but also
just a few chapters in the the
wild varied life of of katie han
and so i'd like to switch gears in a
sense
and ask you when you first heard
about bitcoin it was right after
that mongols biker murder trial i told
you about with the hells angels
ended and that had been a couple months
and you know
after that i had just really done a lot
of violent crime cases over the course
of a decade and i remember thinking
i'm ready to switch to something else
like maybe i'll leave
um i didn't really know what i would do
but um maybe i'll do something else and
my boss came to me and said you know
let's have you put some of these
investigative skills
you've brought to use against criminal
enterprises
to technology and cyber crime and i said
okay
great you know we're here in the
northern district of california it seems
like sensible to do some cyber crime
and he said well here's what we want you
to do we want you to investigate bitcoin
and you know the bitcoin is this kind of
criminal
technology and we need to kind of stop
it
basically and i remember and so that was
around 2012
and i remember going home and talking to
my husband who knew
way more about bitcoin than i did i had
not heard of it at all that was the
first time i ever heard of it
it was 2012 so i was i feel like i was
kind of late to the party i mean
it was the satoshi white paper was in
2008 this was four years later and i had
never heard of it
and my husband told me you might want to
you know
learn what it is before you go around
talking about how you're going to
prosecute it because it sounds
a little foolish and i said well what do
you mean he said well look at this wiki
page and tell me if you think you know
you could prosecute it after and
the more i learned about it i pretty
quickly realized that it would be like
saying i'm going to prosecute cash
or i'm going to prosecute you know the
internet or something like that like
it's not
it's not possible number one and it's
also not desirable
but what instead ended up happening was
prosecuting some of the nefarious
uses of cryptocurrency just like we
prosecuted like i said like i prosecuted
a 25 count indictment for
mortgage fraud conspiracy you know and
they used cash and they used
wires so too here were some cases like
we talked about mount gox we talked
about the silk road twist
there was also the btce case there
there was criminal use of cryptocurrency
so we prosecuted some nefarious use
cases of it
and in the course of that i ended up
starting to get to know some of the
early players in the crypto space tim i
also started realizing more and more
what i had kind of
realized early on which is this doesn't
seem all criminal it seems like there
are actually a lot of people trying to
build some really important products and
services that can be used for good
and so that was kind of how i frankly
got into the space
early days now i was in the government i
always joke like
i bought bitcoin earlier than anyone i
know unfortunately it was undercover in
the government so i never kept any and i
of course never bought any when i was in
the government which is probably a shame
because
you know i don't need to tell you what
the price was back then
okay so and feel free like we can always
edit later right but i'm
curious when you got to know these some
of the earlier players in crypto i mean
i did read
one quote that i thought was fantastic
from
uh i mean we can mention him by name of
course but he said he was he was
terrified of you
and this is uh zuko wilcox
and uh which which makes sense all right
i mean it does make sense on a bunch of
levels but
how many of those early contacts do you
think
played nice because they in their mind
had the
sort of maximum of keep your friends
close and your enemies closer
or through other motivation for other
reasons right you are very good at
developing rapport but i have to imagine
that a lot of these people were
hesitant or tentative or had some
misgivings
about engaging i'd love to just hear you
speak to that if anything comes to mind
well that's the first i
thought of it but it's an interesting
way to think about it but keep your keep
your enemies close
i think what ended up happening though
because i did establish the
government's first crypto task force
back in those days which was comprised
of
a bunch of different agencies i think
what ended up happening it might have
started out that way tim
and i can certainly appreciate why now
being in the space it's like i now
encounter people all the time like oh we
don't want to talk to the government and
you know i think that's just born of
they don't really know that there are a
lot of people in the government
and not everyone thinks the same thing
in the government right it's made up of
hundreds of thousands of people
and some people yeah big organization
right
right um and then once you actually
start making the connections and meeting
people they realize you know you're not
so bad like it doesn't seem like you
want to you know close every
like we thought that you just wanted to
close down everything
you know it turns out that maybe you
just want to keep bad actors off
x y or z platform and you know turns out
we want that too right a great example
of this is you know coinbase and you
know i'm on the board of directors of
coinbase now fast forward several years
you know coinbase did a great job of
this in the early days like i don't
think it was about
keeping me an enemy away i think it was
more about it's not good for their
business to have criminal activity on
the platform
sure i mean they don't you know it's not
like they're cozying up to the
government either but
i think it's you know every kind of
pragmatic and good business leader
thinks
why would you want a bunch of nefarious
activity on your platform
especially if you're trying to build a
business to kind of change the world so
i think you might be right though in the
early days but fundamentally
after they saw some of the bridge
building that we in the government
in those early days started trying to do
and we did things like we hosted a
summit where we
it was invite only but we invited some
of the early folks in the space
i did this with a number of different
agencies and then the agencies would
come in and talk about what their
equities were and i think that kind of
two-way street and dialogue is really
important
because what you want is you want you
know you mentioned zuko i want zuko to
hear
you know what are some of the
consequences of privacy coins
and i want people in the government to
hear what are some of the real benefits
of privacy coins
and i think it's a very very very smart
guy i mean
very very very very smartly um
i remember meeting him actually i
remember exactly um
what you're talking about because i
remember meeting him and i've kept in
touch with him
since that time but you know i even
remember bitstamp which was an early
crypto exchange which was in slovenia
they featured
in our silk road twist case we talked
about earlier and i remember i needed
their cooperation for some records
and i i remember them thinking oh this
u.s prosecutors are coming we think it's
a trap you know and
the i didn't the state department told
me you can't violate the sovereignty of
slovenia
we can't have you meet on slovenian
ground unless this this and this are
followed and i said what
i'm going to lose the evidence the guys
are willing to meet with me now and they
said
well we did just seize a yacht in a dea
case off the coast of croatia maybe we
could arrange the meeting there in
international waters i said okay
if they didn't think i was coming to if
we convince them i was not coming to
trap them if i suggest a
deac yacht to meet on i'm pretty damn
sure they're gonna cancel the meeting um
just casually drop that one in yeah just
meet me offshore
guys i'm really not trying to set you up
um
but anyway long story short we ended up
meeting in in slovenia i hope we didn't
violate
any sovereignty or anything there but we
ended up meeting
and that was early days and you know i
think they ended up seeing what we were
trying to do
and realizing it was actually good for
the space
and ended up providing us with the
records we needed
so amazing and it's not just bitstamp or
coinbase i think a lot of
companies especially over the last
several years have
tried to proactively engage with
regulators but i've also like i said i
think just as
important is that government also for
its part
keep in touch with the crypto industry
and why do i say that
one key reason is because this
technology is changing so fast and i
think like when i talk to my old
government colleagues they're like god
we just kind of finally had mastered
bitcoin and then we have eth
and now we have these other you know
dozen and now of course we have over a
thousand crypto assets it's really hard
for government
um employees with kind of the training
available
to keep up with this technology frankly
it's not just government place it's hard
for any of us even those of us in the
space
to keep up with how fast-moving this is
so i think there's also
just like an important education and
training component that benefits the
government to have these more open
dialogues and
of course if crypto projects feel like
the government's just gonna out to shut
them down
they're not gonna be willing to provide
that two-way street so i think
it's really win-win to have these
conversations i don't want to be naive
or pollyannaish about it i'm not saying
like one
the crypto industry and the government
should team up and you know spend every
day together nothing like that but i do
think this kind of
ongoing dialogue is really important
yeah i agree also because we're not the
only country
developing you know blockchain based
technologies and cryptocurrencies
right i mean right i just like
artificial intelligence so it's
important to have an informed global
perspective and geopolitical perspective
when thinking about a lot of these
things
just for context for people who are
interested zuko is
the i think he is still ceo of the
electric coin company ecc
which is a for-profit company leading
the development of what is known as
zcash for those people who want to look
into that
now on the pro
let's just focus on crypto not
blockchain explicitly for a second but
on the on the pro crypto let's say pro
btc
bitcoin side you have kind of true
believers
who can sometimes paint with broad
strokes and miss
a lot of nuance and details then on the
anti
crypto side you you find a similar kind
of militant
anti-crypto people who have
somewhat maybe naive or simplistic
arguments
right my understanding is that you
it was in mexico city of all places
that you debated paul krugman is that
right yes that's right
who publicly said that you give the best
thesis for crypto he had heard now he's
notoriously anti-crypto
what was it about your argument that he
found
compelling if you remember well i don't
want to say he said i was compelling
he just said i think the best defense
but um i don't want to get some
i i don't want to get some you know
angry
tweets i don't want to get some angry
tweet from paul krugman saying you know
i
never said i was compelling katie um
right right he said
he's like i said it was the best of the
worst yes right or whatever exactly
exactly but um but to the extent that he
said all right this is this is some of
the better
this is some of the better material i've
heard what was it well i think
one thing was and i'm not let's just
even back take a step back
and zoom out because i've encountered
many people who are skeptical like paul
not just paul krugman but as you can
imagine
many many people and i think one thing i
always emphasize
is this is not just about currency well
first of all it's not just about bitcoin
and speculation
and it's also not even just about
currency there's this whole world to
crypto
and that's one of the reasons i've
stayed in crypto is it really
is so interesting to me and that it
brings together so many different
elements
tim of society and different verticals
it brings together
economics computer science technology
but also as you just referenced
geopolitics
finance and certainly law and policy i
mean i could go on and on and now even
art we'll talk later i hope about nfts
or non-fungible tokens but
really there are so many things that
crypto touches
and so one of the things i tried to do
with paul krugman and with others
is to illustrate you know the good
because so much of what i hear is oh
it's for money laundering it's bad and
i think that's a really ill-informed
view like i said without
cryptocurrency we would not have solved
some of our cases without that
blockchain technology one of the things
i try to do is focus on
here are a lot of the good things
happening with crypto and i think
gosh we don't have time i could go on
and on for so long telling you about
some of the good stuff going on so i
i did try to focus him and others away
from just thinking it's only about
money and it's only about speculation
because to me it's about so much more
nfts nfts oh god
you said you said you said let's you
said let's talk about them so let's talk
about them let's do it
okay well um yeah well yeah walk us
through it okay well first of all
i hate calling them by acronyms but and
i did it myself i know so i'm guilty but
nfts let me just break it down what that
is because i think one of the problems
today in crypto is it feels so
inaccessible to people they tell me
i don't understand it i can't like wrap
my head around it and i said you know
okay if i can learn it you can learn it
and part of it is just i think
the industry needs to do an even better
job and we've already improved as an
industry but we still have work to do
on being able to speak plain english in
terms that normal people can understand
you know it's just like there's all this
fancy crypto babble and that's true not
just in crypto by the way
that that was certainly true in law and
in government like
each area or industry has its words
right that
make it feel inaccessible to people and
i try to break that down i did it in law
too it's like
you know you use all these latin terms
in law like what does that actually mean
so nft is like that and nft
stands for non-fungible token and it's
basically fancy cryptobabble that just
means
it's a special kind of token and by
special i mean unique because you know
of course
fungible means not unique and this is a
non-fungible token
so it's a unique token that lives on a
blockchain that tracks something
unique like art or a collectible but
it's different from the usual kinds of
tokens like bitcoin or ethereum because
like i said an nft is not fungible
it's unique it's one of a kind so it
could represent you know an image a
piece of music a video
and in fact him it's it's uh it's
actually kind of serendipitous we're
talking about nfts first of all the
spaces you know as you know
um very active right now but i actually
just acquired an nft my first one
and then someone also gave me an nft so
i now actually own
two digital works of art that are unique
on the blockchain that can't be
replicated that if i ever wanted to
i could sell they're just like regular
art
um but they're digital and they're
unique and that's one of the things
crypto does because people say well wait
can't you copy it whatever
with cryptographic principles
you have digital scarcity so whereas you
could
previously copy a photograph this is
digitally scarce
you can enforce digital scarcity and
that's a really big idea to get your
head around
but the idea is that if i wanted to sell
you
and i'm not going to because i just
acquired it but if i wanted to sell you
my nft my really cool nft that i got
from an artist in spain
he created it and minted it the really
cool thing here
is he gets a cut
if i sell it to you so the content
creator
the artist instead of you know going to
a bunch of middlemen
actually gets a cut of all future
transactions and i think that's really
cool
could you just walk us through
a use case because even for me sometimes
i have
difficulty envisioning this in some
concrete respect right so is it a
what does it look like to give someone
an nft
right do you actually see the image it's
associated with or is it just a
yeah you know something like a hardware
wallet that you then later do
something with i'd love to just have you
give us an example
sure so it's both so you can display it
and in fact there's a whole
kind of industry that i suspect will
grow up and by the way one of the
interesting things is we know what the
use cases are today
what i think is very interesting is we
have no idea what the use cases are
going to be tomorrow
just like when you know the iphone came
out who knew that
the camera and gps in your pocket would
spawn things like uber
ride sharing and gig economy i mean i
don't know
what later use cases there might be with
nfts i know that right now
there's actually a company i think it's
in florida where you'd sell
nft or digital art frames so you can
certainly display it but like you said
you could also put it on a hardware
wallet the point is
it's yours it's like a bearer instrument
but it's
digital and i think so much of our lives
today are moving from the
offline physical world to the online
world
um like think about how much time we all
spend online now and connected
doesn't it make sense that goods would
also start to move
online right like and you might say well
what do you mean and i would tell you
well
you used to have books like they held in
your hand but now there are digital
books you used to have
cassette tapes but now we have spotify
and streaming and stuff so
i think that art and collectibles
and other kinds of pieces of content are
going to follow a similar trajectory but
to answer your question about making it
more practical
do you follow sports i don't personally
follow a lot of sports but do you follow
sports like nba
but i am aware of i don't know if this
is utilizing the same technology but
a company i think it's based might be
based in france
called so rare i don't know
so rare which is which is like it's
limited edition
collectibles like football meaning
football in the european sense
cards and so on but i don't let's
pretend that i follow sports because a
lot of people listening do
okay yeah so so rare you gave an example
of one another one that's in our
portfolio that's been in the news a lot
lately so full disclosure we're
investors
um is dapper labs and through a
partnership dapper has done with the mba
they've created this thing called nba
top shots this is kind of like a big
going on right now it's like i said in
the news a lot a lebron james video
highlight just sold for seventy thousand
dollars
you could buy the steph curry three
pointer you know if you wanted to spend
just over twenty five thousand
think of it as like a digital sports
collectibles so an nba top shot
basically captures a moment from a big
game and it creates this unique
virtual asset that has limited supply
and so it can increase in value
and i think the best way to think of it
tim is think of it like how people used
to collect
rare baseball cards so that this is the
digital digitally scarce version
2021 version of a rare collectible
and then you can trade them in all kinds
of ways that are really neat so
like i say who knows what is next i just
think that's it that's another example
of
an nft that people and including
many of your listeners might have heard
about with this nba top shots and
you know i don't know what sports could
be next but presumably
if they're in the nba you know you can
imagine there are all kinds of
collectibles that one could put on this
you you mentioned
rightly that it's impossible to predict
the range of future applications and use
cases
for these technologies in the early days
right i mean it would be like trying to
envision some type of immersive virtual
reality when you were first on
like aol dial up and
technology not so much it would just it
would just be so far beyond
the scope of imagination for most people
for all people really on some level
since these things can emerge over time
what do you expect
some of the probable or possible
developments might be in in crypto
or blockchain over the next three to
five years
if you were and obviously this isn't
couched as advice of any type
oh no our lawyers won't let us do that
right we're not giving any advice
no advice informational entertainment
purposes only
but as someone who's immersed in this
day in day out
and really at the bleeding edge right
you're going to see things at the edges
first
what are some of the kind of events or
developments that you would be
unsurprised to see in the next handful
of years well i think the two that come
to
top of mind for me one is just mobile
payments and
um we have a company in our portfolio so
again full disclosure i'm not trying to
plug i'm just trying to give you
an illustrative example and it's called
cello
and they've built their own blockchain
and they just launched that's uh c-e-l-o
c-e-l-o yep and they just launched um an
app on top
called veloura and the best way i can
describe this is venmo for the
developing world
or basically venmo for the rest of the
world also
it's basically a way to exchange value
that's pegged to the dollar
okay so it's not pegged to other
volatile assets it uses
an innovation called stable coins which
we can put a pin in
if you want and come back to so the
important thing is it doesn't
the value stays the same of this
particular crypto
currency and you don't need a bank
account to use it
because it's a cryptocurrency it's
distributed and decentralized so it
doesn't
rely on a central authority and all you
need is a mobile phone and why this is
really powerful
is because you know for us sitting here
in the u.s you know
most of the us is banked although
there's a lot of people who are
under banked but for three billion
people in the world and and probably
more than that
they're unbanked and they have
smartphones
um and transferring value is like a kind
of basic human need right everyone needs
to transfer value
like no matter who you are you need to
transfer value at some point
to get something right maybe it's to get
food or shelter or whatever you need to
transfer value no matter where you are
well it's really hard it turns out for
people who don't have bank accounts
to do get access to basic financial
products and services
like money transfer so what do they have
to do a lot of them they have to go pay
platforms you know i'm not going to name
names but certain incumbents
and those incumbents take a lot of fees
and so with ven uh with like a venmo for
the world if you can imagine it on your
phone with your cell phone number in
fact
tim if you want after the show i can uh
send you some
uh send you a couple dollars just so you
can see how quick and instant it is
um but here's the difference because you
might tell me because people do
well who cares that's just like venmo i
have that no here's the difference
venmo is a digital iou this would be
like
it's basically replacing you tim flying
from austin
to me here in california and handing me
cash that's the only way we know
we have the better instrument right that
no one can ever disrupt or screw with
and this is how something like mobile
payments in the crypto context
so like cello works is i'm actually when
i send you sello
i am transferring you the bits and bytes
i'm transferring you the bearer
instrument
and there's no central authority that
can like freeze your account or shut it
down
you actually have basically what's like
cash
once you get it and again here in the us
you know
we have venmo we have paypal we have
bank accounts i think a lot of people in
the world
don't have those things and so we forget
often here in our bubble
that these products and services are
really important to a lot of people in
the world
and are really societally beneficial i
think of it kind of like long distance
remember
i think we're around the same age but
like you remember how you used to have
to pay a long distance bill like if you
called anywhere
well now you have facetime or voip and
all these things disrupted that so now
it's free and that was really beneficial
for consumers
i think that's going to happen also with
mobile payments where instead of paying
you know sometimes 20
in remittance fees and by the way 20
i've actually seen some cross-border
payments cost even 30 percent
and they're also slow anyone who's ever
sent an international wire knows that
takes a really long time
they're also you know you have to pay
tremendous fees the poorest
and the people can least afford them
bear the brunt of those fees
in my long distance example we were all
paying the same long distance rates
that's not true with the underbanked and
unbanked so i think
mobile payments is one area that we're
very excited about
at andreessen for crypto and it's not
just cello there are lots of other
projects that are doing that
as well uh and then the other one i
would mention is
because i think it's important for
content creators and now we have you're
running your own podcast um
but as we have more and more content
creators creating content
and influencers there's one of our
portfolio
projects is called rally and it allows
creators and influencers to create and
issue their own branded currency
um and the the unique thing here
is that i know i i can already see your
tim tim coyne
timmy tokens timmy tokens i want to buy
some of those i'm betting on that one
tim
um it's not investment advice um but
i'll trade you some timmy tokens for
your nifties i really i really hope
people are referring to nfts as nifties
i think they might but rally if this
allows timcoin
it can allow people who to connect
directly with their fans and you know
you have a lot of fans and a lot of
listeners already but imagine a content
creator just getting started
this enables fans who discover that
content creator early on to share
in the economic upside of that content
creator in a way that's really cool
and then you know they're economically
incentivized to kind of spread the word
if you will
but the bottom line is it gives this
content creator and the fan the ability
to share in the upside
instead of just giving a lot of upside
to intermediaries
so i think that's another area that
we're starting to see
and that we're going to continue to see
in the time range you gave me because
you gave me i think three to five years
so mobile payments
content creators that's what i'd say
thank you
i would love to also ask you to comment
on the next three to five years from a
different perspective and that
is the government slash regulatory
perspective
so these technologies in some cases are
poorly understood
not just within government but certainly
across the board i mean there's so many
misconceptions
there are good uses well let's just call
them benevolently uses
malevolent uses and sort of gray area
uses just as there would be with any
instrument if we're talking about
currencies right in the case of cash for
instance
and i think that the you know the
volatility also involved with
many aspects of cryptocurrency are both
incredibly attractive and alluring but
also incredibly
terrifying not only to those
participants who are
in the game so to speak but those who
are the rule makers
and i would love to know
what you would not be surprised to see
on that front
what i would not be surprised to see
okay i'm trying to and that's an awkward
question but like
what you think might likely happen i'm
not asking you to be nostradamus but
you've just
been both you've been on so many
different
sides of this that you seem like a great
person to ask like
what what kind of like announcements
would you not be surprised to see we're
like yep could have seen that coming
yep well i think you're going to start
seeing more and more countries
creating um their own versions of their
own cryptocurrency pegged to their
currency so i would not be surprised to
see that
i think you know look i think there is
some
thought on the part of some in
government that you know oh
crypto it's the wild west they don't
want any regulations they don't want any
laws
i think that's not true i think most in
the crypto space
what is not wanted is regulatory
uncertainty they don't mind regulation
they just want to know what are the
rules so that i know how to follow them
because
that's much easier than like we have no
idea what rules apply to us and
therefore we have to like
be like you just said nostradamus they
just want more
regulatory certainty tell us what the
rules are so we can follow them
and i think the risk is that
the u.s starts to offshore and chill
this technology
if they continue along the path with
kind of regulating by speech
or you know and by the way it's not even
speeches sometimes i hear oh you know so
and so said this and
did you hear what the treasury secretary
said and then you go actually
that's the media reporting the speech
right it's like you go
um read the actual speech and it doesn't
say that the problem is
that's what crypto entrepreneurs in the
u.s are hearing
and it is i do think starting to
offshore
we run the risk of offshoring or
chilling some of this activity i mean
if you think about what regulators care
about they care about things like
consumer
protection they care about money
laundering they care about national
security
and so do i i mean i dedicated you know
12 years to being in national security
and you know
against money laundering and consumer
protection i devoted a large part of my
career to it
but i do think that misses the forest
for the trees because to me
tim the bigger national security threat
or consumer protection threat for that
matter
is offshoring all of this activity and
let me tell you why i mean we already
know that
china has developed a digital version of
its cryptocurrency
and it wants to export that to you know
south america
to africa and so that's
problematic if we have china starting to
control
starting to threaten and this is going
far i don't mean to suggest that we're
going to have
the u.s dollar being upset as the global
reserve currency overnight
but you could see play this out a couple
decades this happens
so that's a terrible national security
threat also consumer protection
you know if consumers can't have access
to certain products and services
in the u.s that they want us consumers
guess what with an internet connection
now and
certain kinds of vpns they can just go
to
overseas platforms and those are not as
good
i think by and large at providing
consumer protection so i just hate to
see this
activity kind of just moving offshore
and i think we really need to
be careful because i'm starting to see
the beginning of it happening already
and i'm trying to of course
work to do whatever i can to make sure
regulators
understand how powerful this is and how
powerful it is to the economy and to
national security and not to lose this
opportunity i mean can you imagine tim
if in the early days of the internet
like we had said the internet's bad we
shouldn't have this you know and then
think of all the entrepreneurs who moved
to the us to build kind of companies and
services we now have that was like
huge benefit to the us economy that they
came here
and it was a huge benefit that we
weren't passing laws or
you know giving speeches saying that
it's bad
that they wanted to stay here and build
those companies so
right equally equally paramount to those
people who were
us nationals who developed the
technology right if they feel like
it feel like they can better develop it
or
humans humans let's face it also if they
can more directly profit
in building a company outside of the us
with technology that for some reason has
been forboden
or hamstrung in such a way to be less
financially feasible in the u.s then
you're going to drive offshoring
right yeah absolutely we see that with
certainly with
different types of taxation and so on
related to royalties and how different
countries treat things
yeah very differently and you you just
see the flow of
operations and headquarters of companies
you see that in the united states
certainly
and particularly now right with work
from home with covid with
people realizing oh you can have teams
remotely
now yeah yeah
it's uh you know i pulled my audience at
one point
on the question of
whether or not a developing country and
i sort of made an assumption there but
which developing country would be the
first to embrace
bitcoin or other crypto as a reserve
currency and it was
fascinating to see the responses and i
put up
as the image a photograph of a 100
trillion dollar bill that i was gifted
from the reserve bank of zimbabwe from i
think 2008 i can't recall exactly
and the comments were really interesting
i'm very fortunate to have some
some really bright followers and also a
very global
audience so people spoke to the
there were venezuelans talking about
huge underground crypto economy that
already exists in venezuela
but that you know taxes might be paid in
the sort of state
run currency but that all let's just
call it peer-to-peer or other
transactions would begin to take place
in crypto
it was very interesting to see the range
of responses related to that do you have
any
any wagers or guesses as to if you had
to characterize the type of country or
the country
that would embrace digital currencies
in a very powerful way
do you have any thoughts on where that
might land yeah do you mean the people
or the government like because i think
that's different i think the populist
oh interesting well the populous i think
it's what you've mentioned
you mentioned venezuela and zimbabwe and
of course any
uh economy where there's been
hyperinflation people are searching for
an alternative i mean
um i know exactly the the trillion
brazilian dollar note you're talking
about i mean i've seen them before
um and venezuela you know i've actually
seen videos you can
pull this up on youtube people literally
burn bags of cash
because there has no value and it takes
up too much room i mean it's just
it's really tragic so i think any for
the populace
any economy um where there's
hyperinflation i think we're going to
see that
and then in terms of for governments
i mean you see some small i think the
the smaller
you know nimble governments will
probably possibly
beat us to the punch us being the u.s
and i'll come back to that but
uh you know you talk about digitally
first governments like think about
estonia or some of the you know
yeah estonia i'm very interested in
following they have to be thinking very
deeply in tracking this very closely
yeah well and i think it's also like an
industry you know like delaware
is like the haven for corporate law in
the us you know every
like companies at delaware you know what
to me i wonder like
what jurisdiction is going to attract
a lot of frankly economic development
by being you know welcome and open to
this i think that'll be interesting i'm
curious to ask you
your listeners what surprised you most
in in the response like you mentioned
venezuela that's not a surprise zimbabwe
was there anyone tim that stood out that
surprised like
you well i think that
surprise i mean i think the response
that came
in multiple times
that i wanted to reflect on and i should
say also i am not
by any stretch of the imagination i do
not consider myself a cryptocurrency nor
blockchain expert in any respect i mean
that would just be laughable
if i were to sit down at a group dinner
with anyone who
is actually on the computer side of this
who who understands these things
in detail like a vitalik or there's a
long long list right
yeah now that having been said i am a
student of
currency and the concept of money right
just the origins of money i remember
reading a book called i believe it was
the biography of a dollar which was
written a long time ago
and that i found really really
to be a helpful one-on-one education on
the emergence of money
and you know the decoupling or unpegging
of the us dollar from the gold standard
and so on
the response that came up multiple times
that
i thought was worth contemplating on
some level
was in effect tim you're asking the
wrong question
and you know there's some looking at one
here you know respectfully i think that
perhaps your question is off point or
reserve currencies held by central banks
or other monetary authorities as part of
forex reserves the whole point of
bitcoin is to eliminate the central bank
eliminate fractional reserve banking
eliminate reserves altogether to remove
that right so the re-framing of the
question or the pointing out that
perhaps my question is
off base i found brain stretching
and thought-provoking for me as as
someone who's really not
an expert in the global flow of capital
and also the separation of as you said
sort of the
populist use of capital and currency
from state mandated policies around
money and also control of supply
of money and the idea
i think that those could be very
different things right is sort of to me
still a pretty novel idea because we're
like okay we all use
dollars in the u.s and like i just paid
for lunch with
cash that i got out of an atm which is
very old-fashioned did you really
i know i know and uh
very old-fashioned and kind of silly
also in the days of covet but had some
cash
and so the idea that what the government
talks about
as money and the money i use day to day
for my common transactions being
different is still pretty uh unusual an
idea to me yeah and that's as someone
who spends a reasonable amount of time
thinking about
cryptocurrency right well you probably
have though like i mean at some level
certain companies become so omnipresent
like for
like for me it's amazon for example you
know and they give you
kind of credit and it's not amazon
dollars but it's you know
you never get the credit back on your
credit card and you think who cares it's
on the amazon platform i'm going to use
that currency again i mean is that a
currency
i think i think that's interesting i
think just going back to your question
is
you know one thing i spend a lot of time
thinking about is
will the us government kind of embrace
some of the properties of cryptocurrency
and create
a u.s you know dollar that is a
cryptocurrency
and i think you know if you hear jerome
powell or others talk about it i think
they
they say they're several years away and
i just wonder if that is too late
i think it is frankly and i one thing i
spend a lot of time thinking about is
you could imagine a private
cryptocurrency that's pecked at the
dollar you could also imagine a public
cryptocurrency pegged to the dollar
one of the things that the us did well i
think in the days of the internet
um and the internet the government us
government had had start because they
helped develop it
they're much more behind on crypto i
think
one thing i spend time thinking about is
would there ever be
some kind of private public partnership
you know if they said okay wow
china's really developed this or you
know maybe the european central bank or
whatever
name your central bank of choice we've
really got to get with this and we have
some really smart people in the private
sector
and private companies and these problems
of distributed computing are hard
problems to solve i mean
i'm on the board as you might know of dm
i know facebook and many other
council members have devoted legions of
top engineers to kind of building that
blockchain
it's not easy and so do we think we have
that already
resident at you know the fed or
something i i really think the
one idea is to have a private public
partnership but then as you point out
there
are other decentralized systems that are
working already
like bitcoin i mean bitcoin is volatile
but now you also have stable coins and
you have wrapped bitcoin
i don't want to talk too much because
like you said crypto is like religion at
some point you have like maximalists
and i'm a crypto maximalist i'm not a
particular asset maximalist
but i do wonder if you know what what
will win
um and what is going to have a good go
to market first and i think
fundamentally what's going to start
getting used
first and early adopted because and
obviously
already bitcoin is the grandfather at
being you know developed in 2008 but who
will get
enough market share earliest because it
just there's real network effects right
and so
if the us government develops a digital
crypto dollar in you know whatever i'm
making up a year here 2028
has it already been overtaken that's
some of what i think about
it's a serious question a huge
opportunity and a gigantic threat from a
geopolitical perspective right i mean
it's
it seems kind of like hard to overstate
yeah
how big that is in the game of
risk that is played around the globe
i mean it's just gigantic yeah another
another question that comes to my mind i
don't have an answer to this but
is what factors or events would
lead to a decrease in bitcoin volatility
to the extent that larger
institutional investors like pension
funds
and endowments and sovereign wealth
funds
begin to allow bitcoin to play within
their portfolios in the way that they
might treat gold
right so if they if they have certain
rules which of course they tend to
which might say you know if x y and z
has a drawdown of more than
20 they get cut like they're out you
know what point
is the curve smoothed enough
that a small percentage of assets that
are allocated to something like gold or
gold like equivalent
begin to get shifted to bitcoin because
it doesn't take
percentage-wise a very large shift
to start to have a tremendous impact on
bitcoin i just don't know what those
events are i don't know if you have any
thoughts
yeah well my first thought when you said
20 shift i thought that's child's play
tim
20 volatility it's nothing but
yeah i was actually thinking about some
of the recent events with uh you know
hedge funds and gme and all that
yep oh right right right of course um
well i think look here's what i think
about bitcoin i think it's still early
days
although it's 2008 it's been around
since 2008
it is still early days and i think we're
going to see adoption in waves and again
this is not a price prediction no
investment advice
etc etc i know i'll have all those
disclosures but i do think that we'll
see waves of it and we're still in the
early
days but you are starting to see i mean
you saw i'm sure
um elon musk's tweet about or i guess it
wasn't his tweet but it was the
s1 the tesla file that says they're
putting some of their treasury and
into bitcoin and and it's not just that
right microstrategy
and there are a couple other companies i
know that are looking at that and i
think those are kind of
early examples of companies putting
small portions of treasury into it and i
think
we'll see another wave i suspect where
more and more companies do that
down the road i don't know when that
would be you know we could even see
at some point a wave where certain
governments
might put a small fraction i'm not
talking about a lot i'm talking about
very small fraction you point it out
just like they do with gold
and so i think yes that would obviously
one would think offset volatility but
who knows as you know
bitcoin has been a hugely volatile asset
um
you know which is which is why we have
stable coins um and i'm not knocking
bitcoin at all i'm
obviously a fan of bitcoin and we've
disclosed before we have a sizable
portion of our fund in bitcoin so we are
bitcoin fans but
i would just be completely speculating
if i said i would know what would happen
to the volatility
i think that the best thing i could say
would be that i think we are in waves
and we will continue to say
sea waves of you know you know we see
some early adopters of institutions now
some early adopters of
companies and i think in the next wave
we'll see more and then there will be
another wave
so let's uh come back to you
and i know we have a little bit of time
left
hopefully and i'm looking at a bullet
here in front of me
that i would like to explore and here's
how it reads
or paraphrasing it you've spent lots of
time saying no
to things that your peers thought were
must do
to pursue other paths people around you
thought were the wrong
move what of those
was actually the most challenging i
wanna i wanna try to humanize you a
little bit for folks because i think
that
it's like wonder woman in the bracelets
with the kiss in the old carry with
like the crypto ninja skills i want to
sort of paint a picture of
one of those decisions if it exists i'm
not asking for fiction here but
if you have said no to a lot of things
that people thought you should do maybe
even insisted that you
needed to do to take the path less
traveled
has there been an example where you're
like where it was difficult or where you
did it and you're like god that this
might be a terrible [ __ ] mistake
many times many times um i i don't only
have one example of that i
i sadly or happily have several um
let me think what comes top of mind i
mean i'll tell you one from personal
because you said
you want to humanize me which i
appreciate thank you um
you're welcome you know there was a time
and this is actually a personal thing i
have other professional ones
which we can talk about if you want but
well i actually have one top of mind
professional one okay
personal one you know i was engaged many
many years ago i was engaged
to someone and you know
i don't think he was excited to be
engaged to me and i don't think i was
very excited to be engaged to him
and fortunately we mutually made the
decision that
we were not going to get married it was
pretty early on in the engagement but we
had been
living together and it felt like the
right thing to do on paper you know
everyone around you is saying oh how
perfect
but i think both of us in our heart of
hearts knew that would be a bad mistake
and so telling our families and friends
that there's a sense of like almost
shame you know it was embarrassing but
we both realized it wasn't right for
either of us and so that
felt a bit like a failure at the time um
not a bit it felt like a big failure
at the time and oh by the way talk about
humanizing me
i had to be a bridesmaid in my one of my
best college friends weddings
about a month and a half after that
happened and i just remember
being there and just it was like kind of
really not a great feeling right my my
own wedding's been called off
and again it was mutual but i
actually took the opportunity to move
back to california this was when i was
in dc
i moved back to california and you know
right after i moved here i actually met
my future husband
like super serendipitously and we this
month have our 10-year wedding
anniversary
and so you know that was a that was
something that felt like wow and even in
the
move here it was like wow maybe this was
the wrong call you know maybe i'm going
to just like end up alone forever which
would have been okay
too but you do question it that's a
personal one
that checks the box that's great yeah i
i mean you're welcome to scratch it but
i think this is
this is paints a fuller picture right
we're adding we're adding some
some earth tones and adding adding a
little sun a sunrise to the painting i
think it's good
well uh there's a professional one too
there are a couple yeah
um if you want if you want me to tell
you about that i mean corsa of course
obviously you know i had walked away
from different opportunities in law like
along the way but i was still always
within the realm of law right i was
oh should i go be at this law firm
kravath where i have an offer no i'm
going to pursue my passion and go to dc
and be a prosecutor and you know and i
also had been doing a clerkship on the
ninth circuit when i was told if you
want to stay another year maybe it would
increase your chances to go to the
supreme court which for a lawyer
and a young postgraduate law student was
like a big deal and i said you know it's
not
no it's not worth it to me like i want
to do other things in life
i don't want to do that for another year
you know people thought that was a
mistake and maybe i did at the time too
by the way i ended up clerking on the
supreme court anyway but i didn't know
it at the time
and then i think the most profound one
though was i
really kind of left entirely a career
where i had you know in the law done
things that i had really invested a lot
of myself and time into whether it was
being a prosecutor in the justice
department clark hands supreme court you
know
i had firmly kind of established my
legal career
and i completely left that and pivoted
and you know when i was doing that i was
actually to join the board of coinbase
and when i did that i remember people
around me particularly those of my
friends who were lawyers or from dc or
like what are you doing
like are you you could go be a partner
in this or that firm and
you're going to join the board of a
crypto company i mean you have liability
and crypto
and that's so crazy um you know i
i didn't really look back after i joined
i just
jumped in it did it but i do feel like a
lot of people have told me in my life
you know this is your one shot like you
can't do that because this is better for
your career
and i've definitely been someone who
cares although it might not sound like
it from our conversation because we've
talked
mostly professional stuff i care very
much about living along the way
and you know i grew up overseas one of
my great passions is spending time in
other cultures and with other people and
with my family
and friends and i don't
really want to sacrifice that just for
work
let's we're going to we're going to talk
about two at least two aspects of that
and one is the coin based decisions so
i would like to sort of turn this into a
movie
for a second and i would love to hear
you tell the story
of making that decision because i can't
imagine you walked in you met them
you're like sweet yeah i'm gonna totally
pivot and that's that and i walked down
and i made a phone call and that was it
no i doubt it unfolded that way so
please please tell us the story of how
you made that decision
not at all actually i remember when i
first met brian armstrong who's the
founder of coinbase and i won't talk
much about coinbase because
that company is now in a quiet period as
you know
um so i won't talk about the company but
i can certainly talk about the
circumstances of my affiliating with
the company and i remember meeting brian
and by the way frederson who i don't
know if you've met him but
um yeah very very very very smart guy
yeah and brian
and i remember telling brian you know he
was telling me about communities and i
said oh
i know about about coinbase brian you
know i've been to your office and he
said this was by the way when i was
still in the government he said what
and i said oh yeah i've been with fbi to
your office before you didn't know that
he's like
no i didn't know that it was it was a it
was a friendly visit
it's a friendly visit it was an
informational gathering visit and
coinbase hadn't done anything wrong
um it was just you know part of that
little i talked about you're laughing
but it's genuine no
no but that is one that is a great way
to get
undivided attention
oh it was a friendly visit by the fbi oh
well in that case
totally relaxed yeah yeah well this was
fortunately for brian this it had
happened
years past or before right so right
right
um anyhow i said brian i already know
about coinbase
in fact you know i told you about some
of the bridge building we were doing and
some of the summits we were putting
together
coinbase and not brian himself but like
someone from coinbase
just like many early crypto players
would come to those you know
numerous crypto representatives call
them from the industry would come and
meet with some of the government
folks um i won't i won't say who because
i don't know if i have their permission
but the
bottom line is like a lot of different
folks in the crypto industry it wasn't
just coinbase
so i kind of knew the company already
through
that work while i was at the government
but
i definitely never thought i would be
working in the crypto industry or in
venture capital by the way i guess i
thought i would probably have gone to be
a judge
or a partner and a firm or i didn't
honestly know what i would do but
something in law
right and remember when i joined the
crypto industry it wasn't the cool or
fashionable thing to do it was
like i think i joined in what we call
the crypto winter um and people thought
i was just really crazy that i was
giving all this you know
law stuff up but back to the story of
brian he yeah you know he said you know
i really think that you ought to
consider
partnering with us somehow and i said
well you know i work in the government
so i can't partner with you
um which what he meant is do you want to
come in
and work here and i thought you know
that's a really interesting idea i had
never thought about working full-time
for a crypto company believe it or not
and instead i said you know i really
want to work with a few different
companies
you know i've never been in tech and i
would like to work with a few different
companies
and brian and i'm forever grateful he he
had this kind of innovative thinking
said well then why don't you join our
board of directors
which is again something i'd never
thought of and i
i did jump at that chance now it was a
little bit interesting
timing because i was actually under
consideration for some high-level
government posts at the time
which i won't go into other than to say
that i had to withdraw from those
in order to serve on the coinbase board
and so to serve just for my
clarification to serve on the board
right serving on the board
consumes time and energy but it's not a
full-time job so the
but you to be able to take
that board position would have to
sort of recuse yourself from government
employment is that
is that how it works that's right
separation of church and state
absolutely
absolutely and i had already actually by
that point i had left the government
just to clarify i had already left the
government when i was having this
conversation with brian
but i was thinking of going back in as a
high-level appointee and in fact i was
already going through an fbi background
check
and you know interviewing with all kinds
of senatorial committees
and um so i was already out of the
government but i could not go
back into the government as a political
appointee or otherwise or a judge
and also be on the coinbase board of
course like you said strict separation
of church and state
which is definitely we want to keep it
that way um so when i
took that coinbase board i was really
saying
goodbye i think to a career in the
government and
you know i did make that decision i did
make it actually pretty quickly by the
time i made it
and which i do is something i do i can
obsess and waste a lot of mental energy
on small little decisions tim that
aren't that consequential which is
a big weakness of mine but on big huge
life decisions i'm pretty quick
and i made it and you know there it is
four years over four years later um i'm
still on that board
what was it that made it a fast
yes and not a fast no wow that's a great
question i think in life
someone told me this once and i can't
remember who but it has always stuck
with me and they told me this a long
time ago
in life there is either hell yes or
there's no
and if it's not hell yes it's no is that
a cliche thing i i had never heard
no that's okay that's actually that's
actually something i believe
that was started by derek sivers
oh i didn't know that yeah entrepreneur
who founded a company called cd baby
and one of his rules in his life is hell
yes or no
yeah and it felt like hell yes i hope
that was the right decision i think it
was
you know and from there uh again i'm not
speculating i think you'll do
i think that's gonna prove to be a
pretty good decision
possibly uh on a bunch of levels yeah
yeah well it's been certainly
you know i really one of the things i've
always done is follow my passion
follow my gut and then do stuff that
interests me and
by that measure a hundred percent it was
the right decision
and uh you know it's also given me a
great flexibility now and then
by the way there's that's how i met mark
and ben you mentioned they've been on
your podcast
i actually met mark and ben the founders
of my firm now that i where i'm now
working full-time through my work on the
coinbase board
so you know it was one decision but then
it led to other decisions so who knows
how that's changed
my career trajectory let's see how
exciting
so exciting what a uh remarkable right
turn
you know uh it's just it's just
fantastic
and i said there were two things yeah i
wanted to
to explore the other is
family or specifically kids yeah and the
reason i bring up kids so
we're not going to talk we can talk
about your family certainly but i want
to talk about
the family of one of our mutual friends
her girls
who one of which
one of whom the grammarians out there
will teach me which way it is
is i think 10 or younger wanted to be an
actress and now wants to be a prosecutor
thanks to you and
she the mother
has told me that
she would trade everything that she has
for the influence that you have had on
her girls
uh and girl in this case and
that you are just remarkable with
children and that they are they
gravitate to you
why is that god if you
i don't know i don't know can you have a
talk with my own kids because they don't
gravitate toward me
they tuned me out you know i thought
crypto would be cool to them but you
know mom is not cool
um so if you want to have a word with
them that would be appreciated
uh god i'm not going to be of any help
i'm not a child whisperer to my own kids
but let me i mean
you know i think one of the reasons is
you know i grew up with a mom who always
told me
you can do of course you can do anything
you set your mind to of course you can
you know i don't know that that was true
but the fact is i believed her
and i thought well she says it is it's
my mom and she
you know is a young girl or a young
woman of course you believe what your
mom tells you
at least to a certain age and
i think it was almost a self-fulfilling
prophecy that someone was believing in
you like that that yeah you could do
anything you set your mind to
it might take small little chunks which
we can talk about like i
set goals but then i i you know if
they're audacious i'm not going to
achieve them
just easily right you break them down
into small bite-sized chunks
but i think with kids and i've seen this
just even in teaching you know i've
taught over the years and i have several
students i've seen this with young
people
and with even younger kids
is that really making them feel like
they could do
anything and that really what they need
to do is find what they're passionate
about
and that is exciting and that makes you
really want to work hard
but also i i've always thought as i said
you really want to live along the way
and find and that's why i think it's so
important to find your kind of
sounds cliche but you're calling in life
for work
and i think when i talk about kind of
stories or jobs i just must have
you know i did it out of a passion or a
mission or
you know some purpose and i would hope
that comes through
it's funny you say that it was a girl
because the amazing thing about being a
parent
and i noticed from listening to your
podcast you know
in the past that you you said you don't
have you don't yet have children but the
amazing thing about being a parent is
that every once in a while they just say
stuff that completely pulls you over
and um someone asked my son who's in
elementary school someone asked my son
a couple years ago you know what do you
want to be when you grow up and
tim he said well it's kind of crazy
because what i want to be is a girl's
job
and they said well what's that and he
said either an fbi agent or a prosecutor
that's amazing um
wow and i don't know if it was just the
kind of story and it's not just the
stories it's just like
i think he or other kids i hope
see that i i've been passionate about my
work and it's you know
but as you know from this podcast and
your listeners now you have to find
balance in life and it
it can't be all work and no play but
better when it's
work that you actually really enjoy and
that feels fun
i would love to know how being
passionate manifests itself like
what is the passion that your son
observes like how does he
see or feel your passion that then
sort of leads him to gravitate or even
say like fbi agent right
or this other friend's daughter who's
now saying prosecutor like
what is it that they feel in you because
i can guarantee you there are plenty
of investors i know who if they sat at a
dinner and a kid was present
the kid would tune them out completely
would have
if anything the desire to do whatever
that person the opposite of whatever
that person
does they just it would not
resonate the person nor the content
would resonate at all
and so i'm wondering what it is
that uh sort of enchants these kids
in a sense right what is the passion
that gets how does it manifest
well one thing i i learned and i think
this is not really from being a
prosecutor i think this just dates back
to how i grew up which i don't know if
you know this but i grew up moving kind
of
every couple years at most like the
longest i stayed anywhere i think was
three years
and from places ranging from you know
utah to texas
to then like cairo egypt and overseas in
europe in the middle east and africa
and what that meant was like i was
always the new kid in school
and you had to make kind of fast friends
if you wanted to have any and you had to
really adapt to your surroundings and
find some kind of common ground that you
could
connect with people about right i mean
the people that you're meeting in you
know
utah are very different than the people
you're meeting in zamalik or downtown
cairo
as you might imagine particularly when
you're a young person like the young
friends you're making they have
different interests and
so i think one thing is just i'm used to
being around
people and that's also true by the way
from prosecuting and being around
witnesses
and confidential human sources and
informants and then switching to
venture and being around tech folks and
crypto
people too they're their own class so
i'm just used to being around
a really wide variety of very different
people
and wanting to find a way that connects
with those people
because i want to have relationships
with fundamentally each one of those
kind of communities i just described
or constituents that i just described
and of course children are part of that
right and you've got to
find some common ground and things that
interest them
and it's not about creating a persona or
being phony it's about being
completely authentic but in a way they
can relate to
you know and it's it's also about i
think
my ability to explain stuff maybe your
listeners will disagree maybe i haven't
explained anything clearly on this
podcast
tim but like explaining things clearly
in a way
people can understand and what i mean by
that is you know when i had to go in
front of juries we had to talk about all
kinds of complicated concepts
but you need to break them down in a way
that 12 different people on that jury
can all get no matter their background
no matter their education no matter
their training no matter what field
they're in
and i think the same is true with kids
you know what are they going
can you explain things in a way that
teaches them anything in a way that
excites them i think if if the answer
there is yes
then the rest comes a little i won't say
it's natural but
it's much easier for them to be in
interested in the conversation if you
can make it on a level they understand
yeah yeah definitely makes me think
about one of my favorite books surely
you must be joking mr feynman about the
physicist richard feynman he talks a lot
about his father who is
incredibly gifted in that respect and of
course
richard feynman later went on to become
famous for many things including his
ability to reduce complex
complexity in the world of physics to a
simple demonstration perhaps with an
apple and a
pencil in front of a class and
just uh maybe one or two last questions
for you for this round
and the next one i'll make book related
since i mentioned a book
oh okay are there any particular books
that
stand out in your mind or come to mind
that you have
re-read many times or reread it all
or gifted often to other people
not that i've re-read many times i guess
it's hard to answer the question because
i kind of think of it as through the
filters of life experience like where
were you in your life with the time you
read that book right like
where were you at that moment have you
have you seen that ted talk by the way
the
remembering self versus the experiencing
self it's really good
i haven't but i imagine there's quite a
difference between the two
yeah well it's and this is kind of what
i'm getting at it's like was it the book
that was so good or was it like the
surroundings where you were when you
read it or was it you know the stage in
your life it was like oh my god i'm
feeling the most fit i've ever felt and
i feel great you know
um so it's it's viewed through the lens
of that but i would say
with all those caveats and i haven't
read it many times but
a couple that come to mind one is
memoirs of a geisha i just
i loved that book um i don't know if
you've read it um i always found it
i haven't i haven't read it but i know a
lot about it yeah the first
few drafts were completed and thrown out
by the author who started
afresh until he got the version that you
read which is just mind-boggling to
imagine yeah
i never knew that but i the reason i
loved it so much is i read that book
and i can't believe it's written by a
man because you are convinced as you're
reading it it's written by the geisha
why i just have such a great memory of
reading that book is i read it while i
was
studying overseas in a language school
and i was studying by myself and so i'd
go to dinner every night alone
and you know you feel awkward at the
restaurant by yourself or you know you
could and so i would always have a book
with me and i remember reading that
memoirs of a geisha book
while i was learning a language so that
stands out but the other one
that i really love is palace walk which
is i don't know if you're familiar with
that but it's written
by a nobel laureate nageeb mafuze and
it's set in the turn
of the century or set maybe it's 1920s
cairo
egypt and it just reminds me of cairo
which is a place i kind of grew up as a
kid and
so a lot of powerful memories of
the city obviously it was set in a
different stage
time frame but that's one that i
i love palace walk and that's fiction
yeah it's fiction by nageeb mafuze who i
think was the first arab nobel laureate
he's certainly a nobel laureate
so there's those are some obviously
there's a lot of related to my old kinds
of work which i love
um even though i shouldn't but it was
like the killing of pablo escobar i
thought or the hunting of pablo escobar
i think it's called that's
by mark bowden down black hawk down yeah
under an alone is a good read by the way
tim if you want some more true crime
under and alone what's that about yeah
it's a best-selling new york times book
it's actually remember i told you about
the hells angels mongols case i did well
the agent went deep cover for three
years
and they taught there's a lot of
quandaries they confront
when they're deep cover right living
among these
criminal enterprises they have to fit in
so like what happens when they're asked
to
violate the law and they can't because
they're federal agents you know and how
do they pass that lie detector test and
it's the story of one agent's journey of
living under cover
deep cover um a double life really and
rising up to the top of that gang and
that's a true story so it's interesting
wow god that just seems
it's i i'll have to check it out i mean
it just seems like
such a easy way to identify
who is a possible plant right you just
ask everyone to do
x y or z and then whoever doesn't do it
you're like all right well just to be on
the safe side like
we're gonna take care of you well they
give lie detector tests um
and that came out during that trial i
did is how did you pass the lie detector
test
and the jurors were on the edge of their
seats to figure out how how on earth
the agent that we had embedded passed
this lie detector tests because they
they do administer them
so that's a good read and actually i i
have gifted that i have gifted that book
um it's a quick beach read or or if
you're not a beach guy it's a quick
it's a quick read whatever you might do
with your leisure that's a quick
tequila on the yard exactly
under and alone amazing well katie
it's been so fun to spend time with you
katie han
at katie underscore han on twitter and
you're doing a lot of exciting things
and
i have many new chapters ahead of you
i'm sure
is there anything you would like to talk
about
or any comments you'd like to make
questions you'd like to post things
you'd like to ask of my
audience anything at all that you'd like
to add before we
bring this round one to a close i mean i
guess the only thing i would
ask your audience is just take a moment
to explore crypto it's not really a plug
for an industry
i'm involved with that's not why i'm
saying it it's just mostly because
there's so much written about the
headlines and
i'd love to encourage your listeners to
just explore a little bit more and
realize it's
really not all just about one asset or
speculation
there's a lot of exciting things
happening in the space and the ask i
would have of them is also if they're
not
and i know there are a lot of techies
and people very sophisticated in
technology and technical
among your listeners tim but if they're
not not to get intimidated by it or
think they can't figure it out i had
recently
a female ceo who has in times 100 most
influential people i won't say her name
but i will say very successful across
multiple dimensions
personally professionally and she told
me i need a phd to figure this stuff out
and i just
can't so i'm just not going to do it and
i told her look
there is no phd to be had in crypto and
if there were
it would be outdated the year after it
was granted because the space changes so
fast so
just like don't get um don't let
yourself
intimidate is not the right word but
don't let yourself just think oh it's
too complex i don't want to go dive deep
in it you don't need to dive deep in it
just go learn something
about it that you didn't know and i just
ask that if you're listeners
how would you suggest because there's
there are some great resources
there are a lot of terrible resources
there are a lot of
scams masquerading or fly-by-night
operations
masquerading as how-to content sources
how would you suggest or how might you
suggest someone
learn more yeah as you're describing i
mean we have up on our website which is
i believe it's a16z.com we have what we
have
called a cryptocannon and even that just
what i'm saying proofs in the pudding is
out of date already because we posted it
i don't know when and now you know
there's all this stuff that's changed in
the space so we need to go update
it but we do have this crypto cannon up
that you could learn more on our website
i also think just getting a few folks
who know what they're talking about in
the space and following their writings
on things like medium i mean
one other thing is and i wasn't
intending to plug a portfolio company
here but clubhouse you might have heard
which is an andreas and howard's
investment
i've noticed that on clubhouse there are
a number of sessions
online every day happening on crypto and
it's a great way to just listen in while
you're doing something like i don't know
doing the laundry or you're drying your
hair or you're doing something else that
you don't need to be fully present in
that experience
hop on and put your earpods in and like
listen because there's i i keep seeing
all these sessions on
are we going to call him tim nifti's on
nfts
um on on d5 by the way we didn't even
talk about d5 but on d5
it's like daily there's daily sessions
on all of these things
and you can just listen in and hear what
people are talking about and it's kind
of a great
way to separate like wheat from the jaff
i know it's i think clubhouse
is still invite only but i i i think
that will soon change and
um i know a number of your listeners are
probably already on it but
our website has the crypto cannon um
and then there i've just seen a number
of great medium posts
honestly um our by the way our our canon
our crypto cannon
pulls not not just us i mean we pull um
some of the people we've already talked
about on here their writings on so it's
not just andreas and horowitz and it's
not even just necessarily our portfolio
companies we
kind of search for the content and put
it on our website ourselves as well
yeah you guys a16z have put together a
lot of really good content we'll we'll
link to those in the show notes for
people at tim dot blog slash podcast
you'll be able to find it really easily
we'll link over to that
i hope that nifties if they're not
already called nifties
become nifties i'd be very excited about
that uh
we'll call them child like yeah nifties
for all your future keynotes nifties
and uh they're also as you mentioned
there are some
some very i at least i would consider
very bright people
who make an effort to explain
some of the core concepts uh within
blockchain and certainly comment on on
bitcoin naval ravicon our mutual friend
is one of them he has interviewed on my
podcast on this podcast
nick zabo s-z-a-b-o also incredibly
incredibly sharp and
that episode is also a decent place
to start and it's a great place to start
actually can i tell you
that episode was the first episode i
ever listened to
and it was a while ago that that's an
old episode if i remember
that was a few years a few years ago a
few years ago yeah well actually that's
how i learned about smart contracts
and i remember nick talking about a
vending machine
and i just thought now i can visualize a
vending machine okay that makes sense to
me
um so nepal that episode is a must
listen
thanks for listening yeah yeah that's
amazing yeah we had a blast i was a
a few years ago and the intent of that
episode was to have a conversation that
would be evergreen that would have some
lasting power because like you said
if you're covering the latest
and greatest developments you're going
to be obsolesced
very quickly i mean within weeks or
months you will probably
have said something that needs revision
but we really
started with basic the fundamental
concepts smart contracts
what a ledger might look like what
analogies are helpful
currency itself forget about
cryptocurrency discussing currency and
what that represents
how it's evolved and different
applications
uh so i'll put that in the show notes
for folks as well uh is there anything
else
katie that you'd like to to say or ask
or point people towards
before we adjourn no um thank you so
much tim for having me on this has been
great and thanks to your listeners yeah
i really
appreciate you taking all the time i
know you have a lot on your plate and
certainly you have a lot of exciting
things going on
so i appreciate you carving the space
and you're scheduled to do this
and to everyone listening all the
resources
everything that was mentioned from the
very beginning all the way to palace
walk
and the nick zabo naval rav gun episode
we'll link to in the show notes also
point to the
andreessen horowitz resources at
team.log four touch podcast you can just
search kdktie
and this episode will pop right up and
until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four hour
workweek.com that's four
hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by four
sigmatic which is part of my morning
routine also part of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings
i regularly start with their mushroom
coffee instead of regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list
that's number one i travel with it i
recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the 60
of americans or more who drink coffee
daily consider switching it up
this stuff is amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive
enhancement side easy on the system side
energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious it is
decaf completely decaf and some may
recognize chaga
it is nicknamed the king of the
mushrooms it is excellent for
immune system support so needless to say
i'm focused on that right now myself and
so i will often have that
in the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself
sane cordyceps excellent for endurance
they have a whole slew of
options that you can check out every
single batch is third party lab tested
for heavy metals allergens all the bad
stuff
to make sure that what gets into your
hands is what you want to put in your
mouth and they always offer
a 100 money back guarantee so you can
try it risk-free
why not i've worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling lion's mane coffee i
literally have a mug
full of it in front of me right now and
this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to
39 off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39 percent off it's a lot they're
best selling lions main coffee bundles
to claim this deal you must go to
4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on
their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's
f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com slash tim to get yourself some
awesome and delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
checkout
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle asleep and i'm a member
of that sad group temperature is one of
the main causes
of poor sleep and heat has always been
my nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back on and repeating ad nauseam
but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever
why because i'm using a simple device
called the pod
pro cover by eight sleep it's the
easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
ate sleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite and people were just
raving fans of this so i used it and
here we are
add the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys
you can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot simply go to eight
sleep dot com slash tim or use code tim
that's eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim eight sleep dot com
slash tim for 200 off your pod pro cover
you